e
um uh it being 10:04 I guess thereabouts
um I'll open the finance division 2
hearing and we're meeting today with the
police standards organization so a you
gentlemen uh or ladies whoever's
stepping
up and if you would introduce yourselves
and uh start
in thank you Mr chairman good morning to
uh this body pause one moment yes our
lady has
entered perfect
timing if we just give her a moment to
settle
in proceed whenever you're
ready thank you Mr chairman uh good
morning everyone uh with me here today
uh is our uh business manager Max
Schultz and our uh uh business assistant
manager uh Jessica
Nichols uh for the record my name is
John skippa and I am the director of New
Hampshire police standards and training
uh the mission of New Hampshire police
standards and training is to shape
sustain and strengthen the competency
and professionalism of New Hampshire law
enforcement in service to our
state we're an independent executive
branch agency governed by a 17 member
police standards and training Council we
are not affiliated with any law
enforcement or prosecutorial agency
thereby avoiding potential conflict of
interest with our regulatory function
and desertification
duties we set the hiring educational and
accountability standards for all police
state corrections and probation parole
officers in New
Hampshire we operate the New Hampshire
Police Academy which every full-time
municip
County and state law enforcement
professional must successfully complete
to become a certified uh full-time
police officer in this
state we also operate the part-time
Police Academy which all part-time
police officers must successfully
complete to obtain part-time police
certification we operate the New
Hampshire Corrections Academy which All
State Corrections Officers must
successfully complete to obtain
corrections officer certification
we also provide court security officer
training opportunities for All State
employed security officers working for
the administrative office of the courts
the State Legislative court and other
state agencies that employ armed
security
officers additionally we provide
specialized Advanced and inservice
refresher training at our facility in
conquered and regionally around the
state to assist officers in completing
the annual training requirements to
as part of our responsibility for
regulating over 4,000 certified officers
in our state we convene and rule on
disciplinary hearings excuse me that may
suspend or revoke the certification of
officers that have committed acts of
defined
misconduct who have violated Council
rules or who have committed a crime or
act of moral
turpitude we are an independent
executive
branch as stated earlier uh we provide
services with 28 full-time and 11
part-time positions which include sworn
staff administrative and maintenance
employees our staff is assisted by
adjunct
instructors most of whom are unpaid
volunteers and a small number of
contracted
instructors we operate 77,000 square
foot training facility located on 20.8 7
Acres of grounds across from nhti
which is conquer's community
college with regard regard to uh form e
necessary statutes or rule changes we
are requesting necessary changes to
several statutes Within Chapter
106 first we are requesting a
clarification in the definition of
police
misconduct second we are requesting a
change that would authorize the
appointment of a temporary member to the
conduct Review Committee third we are
requesting a change to clarify the
requirements for reporting an allegation
of police misconduct and lastly we are
requesting statutory language be added
that establishes the law enforcement
accreditation Commission in statute as
it was created pursuant to executive
order
of
6,368
1138 in fiscal year 26 and the same
Target allocation in fiscal year
27 our submitted efficiency budget
request meets those
requirements our adjusted authorized
6,855
27 our fiscal year 26 Governor
6,364 58 represents a
0.94% decrease below the FY 25 adjusted
$441,000 efficiency request of 6,
363,000
988 represents a 0% increase from FY 26
as
requested it is important to note that
police standards and training has taken
on a number of new responsibilities
within this last budget cycle these new
responsibilities are the result of 2022
legislation through administrative rule
changes based on recommendations made by
the governor's law enforcement
accountability community and
transparency commission and through
realignment of responsibilities between
State
agencies SB
376 dfn 2022 session assigned police s
training with providing Crisis
Intervention training to New Hampshire
Law Enforcement Officers with the target
of having at least one officer from
every law enforcement agency uh
trained executive order
20226 assigned police standards and
training with the responsibility of
overseeing the Statewide accreditation
program
for law enforcement agencies this
program is funded by doj grants and a
small general fund operating
budget HB 1682
fn- 2022 session established the law
enforcement conduct Review Committee
under police standards and training this
committee is responsible for overseeing
and reviewing all investigations
regarding allegations of police
misconduct as defined by
Statute through executive 20 22 check
2022-23 point1 has been amended to
increase the number of annual inservice
training hours for all certified Law
Enforcement Officers as a condition of
continued certification from eight hours
annually increasing incrementally to 24
2025 our prioritized needs request in FY
26 included one full-time position for a
law enforcement training specialist one
to assist with court security officer
and general court security officer
training programs the prioritized needs
request was removed during the
governor's review of the budget and we
plan to rearrange and utilize current
Staffing to meet the needs of this
additional responsibility given to us by
the
legislature hb2 item number 2 to this
item has been added as a bill working
its way through the legislative process
the governor's office has directed us to
respectfully request that it remained
hb2 and with regard to the requested
change to the governor's recommended
budget police standards and training has
been working with doit to fill an urgent
need for an IT manager to position
within police standards and training we
currently share an IT manager with many
other agencies and fiscal and GNC have
approved the transfer of funding to
support this position through the end of
the current bium police standards and
training currently has a vacant
full-time administrative position that
we would request to defund for the next
bium and use the salary and benefits
from that position as well as other
funds in our efficiency budget request
to continue to fund the it manager to
position there would be no increase to
the governor's recommend
budget request simply an adjustment of
the current funding
lines PST requests the following changes
to our Governor's recommended budget
request we would ask to defund position
number
18241 and move funds to the to support
the doit position number
14294 it manager 2 the total cost for
this position in FY 26
is
$15,508.57
$1,238 48 which will go into our direct
doit budget funds are requested to be
moved as indicated
below and I would just ask that those uh
record our proposed FY 2627 budget
reflects compliance with Target
allocations set forth by the governor's
office while attempting to appropriately
resource our current obligations of
providing contemporary recruit training
to newly hired officers creating and
delivering in service training
regulating and monitoring compliance
with Professional Standards as well as
preparing to meet the number of new
obligations as
outlined take this opportunity to thank
all of you for listening to our
presentation and we stand ready for any
have go ahead you got a list I just run
through
um I guess just some general things
which I think I'm learning every time
you come learn something new and I
probably need to go back for another um
visit which is always really really
interesting um there you know your
standards regarding the standards do you
coordinate with national standards too
is there information about what or you
know what other police departments are
doing with regards to standards and
training uh thank you for the question
uh representative Murray and in fact we
do uh I am lucky enough to uh be a
member of I adalis which is the
International Association of directors
of law enforcement standards and
training I think they have to come up
with a new name it's a little too long
uh but I get an opportunity to meet uh
with my peers there's 50 of us in the
country and uh it is a tremendous
resource to be able to to sit down both
regionally uh and then nationally to be
able to discuss uh what's going on in
other parts of the country uh and that
that has proven to be very helpful uh I
will uh uh Pat collectively ourselves on
the back uh we New Hampshire uh tends to
be the agency that uh is looked at by
other agencies like hey what are you
guys doing we might want to try that as
well and I am very proud of that thank
you um perhaps I was unaware but I like
you know the paragraph you have here on
the first page with with all the
different carve outs of the part-time
you know the to be certified for
part-time police um certified for
Corrections are those new programs or
there have you more uh clearly defined
those programs that existed before cuz I
was una aware that you had different
levels of um training on that thank you
for that question in fact uh the
full-time Police Academy the part-time
police academy and the uh Corrections
Academy have historically uh been
delivered through police standards and
training and uh the new Academy that uh
just came to us uh through legislative
action in the last session is the uh
program to help train the court security
officers that are hired by the
administrative office of the courts uh
and we are um uh clearly standing by uh
relative to uh this budget process We
Stand ready to deliver that program uh
either as a a full academy uh and then
we also stand ready to Pivot if needed
and uh turn that into what we would
refer to as an inservice program where
we would deliver uh small blocks of
instruction throughout the year uh to
help uh facilitate the training and stay
fiscally responsible as well yeah thanks
that's interesting to see it's it pulled
out specifically for different roles of
law enforcement um about the pricus
intervention training that's gone it
seems there's no money in that here did
it move someplace else because there's
you know the $1 million you reference it
um uh thank you I'm going to ask uh Max
to speak to that it may have just gone
someplace else
thank you for your
question we moved the general funding to
cover shortfalls that would be in our
operating budget to to fill so that we
don't have to ur any layoffs or program
loss but there was a continuously
appropriated fund that's non lapsing
that will continue on through each year
of the budget through the next bium um
that is was through the legislation that
created the funding but it was very
specific to only TR one officer in each
agency and we were using the general
funds to train up to three or four
officers in each agency as well as
provide as much CIT Crisis Intervention
training as possible to police agencies
so that fund that you don't see uh is a
continuously non- laabs sying that
continues to pass on and I I believe
there's around $800,000 left in
there oh yeah I'm looking at page 11 84
um I don't know if that's going to help
you at all where um it was you know $1.1
million program and it looks like it's
gone it in the next year it'll be
$43,750 um I'm assuming that's one it's
like one person has been left in that
Division and if the crisis is if the
training is ongoing can you point me to
where that money is now it it I would
have to ask our business supervisor
essentially but it the money is
continuously appropriated non lapsing so
it doesn't show in our current budget
but and I'm saying in our in our
proposal budget it's in our current
operating budget and will'll transfer
over because it's continuously
appropriated not lapsing so the
remainder of what we haven't spent in
this bium will just simply move over so
you don't see it and that's not
recognized that's not recognized but we
will continue that program uh for up to
one officer in each agency has
legislation
States okay
and on the page before um
1183 can you just explain the um the
maintenance other than buildings and
grounds
um it looks like there was huh there was
maintenance that was done and so that's
finished but then there's um
contractural maintenance that's going up
by a couple hundred thousand um to so
that would be under class 48 yes yeah I
was I was looking at 24 this looks like
that work is done done um 48 it looks
like there's new work that's coming
online so there were a couple things
that were moved around is we had a
software records management software
that was not properly classified in the
last budget that was under class 24
which we moved to the appropriate class
software line so we're funding that in
the appropriate Place uh the other large
change that we had in class 48 is we uh
reclassified two building service worker
two positions for uh janitorial work we
were unable to fill them repeatedly and
administrative Services were unable to
help us fill those positions or even
provide for cleaning of our facility so
we actually uh reclassified those and
then we were able to get uh enough
funding to support a contract for
janitorial services which was actually a
cost reduction over the salary and
benefits of those two full-time
positions so we achieved a cost savings
and we are still having we have a
contract now so we're moving funding
into that line to support the contract
for the B so that's just moving things
around
again
um
and it looks like you're hiring a time
I'm back on 1183 I've got my notes all
over the place um line 50 they're hiring
a temp person is this a new this is a
new
have there no um personal service temp
appointee or temp appointed yes so we
it's two positions uh one is actually my
part-time position and and one is for
our administrative rule coordinator okay
to we have a in the process of redoing
all of our administrative rules and
these are classified as temporary is
that what that
means 50 uh 50 page 11 yes all positions
are classified as temporary part-time
that's how they classifi and these are
all considered part-time positions huh
you and we address the training Council
number 22 you'd like that's in
HB hb2 um or the where you can use some
of the people from the law enfor the
academy for law enforcement details it's
the number 22 um and the other thing I'm
just curious where'd it go it just made
me chuckle um on
1186 food for institutions in Department
that's feeding all your trainees your
that is correct yes they need to be f
um how many sessions do you do in a year
uh for the last two years during the uh
really the bium that we're in now and
the one prior to
uh and and this is reflective of uh what
we're seeing going on not only in the
state of New Hampshire but Nationwide
quite frankly uh there was a just a
tremendous glut of
officers uh that left the business right
after uh the police reform initiatives
hit um a couple of years ago and uh
there was a large group of people that
were still
applying and so there was this massive
uh vacancy rate across the state and
then we had a very large group of people
that were hirable and these agencies
hired them we had to increase our
training to uh include overlapping acmis
and we ran four full-time
policey uh over the last two and a half
years uh and that was to kind of take on
the address the urgency of turning
around these new recruits to fill those
massive open positions uh across the
state uh candidly uh the staff at police
engine training really had to up their
game and they were uh uh they were
really starting to get
burnt uh at the same time we started to
see the urgency kind of decrease a
little bit there was less people in the
pipeline and the vacancy rates were not
nearly as bad so this year uh the the
sitting class right now uh is the
beginning of a return to only running
three full-time acmis a year we're going
to be running two Corrections acmis this
year uh we are running right now now one
part-time
Academy we will look at the numbers for
a part-time Academy if we have to run a
second one this
year and uh we stand ready to deliver
for
uh court security officer
acmy uh but again we we are also going
to be very uh flexible with regard to uh
whatever uh our Collective budgets will
allow us and if uh if AOC is not in a
position uh
to deliver people for a full Academy
then will pivot back to the the
inservice model so three full-time one
part-time possibly
two two Corrections acmis standing by on
four court security officer acmy for
2025 and I'm interested uh size of the
class age range and instate out of state
men women
uh thank you for that question and and
we can really dial down I don't have
those specifics on uh gender and age but
we can certainly get that for you uh we
uh run now uh 65 recruits per
academy uh understanding that we're
going to see an attrition rate uh you
know usually the first week people
decide that this is not for them and uh
and that's fine uh we usually lose about
on average 2.5 per class in the first
week uh unfortunately we may see an
additional one in every class on average
that has uh a blip on a weekend that all
of a sudden uh prevents them from
pursuing law enforcement in New
Hampshire and um we'll run three of
those classes a year at 65 uh
Corrections Academy will also run up to
uh 55 although we're just not seeing
those numbers and that is no fault to
anybody it's just a recruitment and
retention issue that we're facing right
now
particularly in in the area of uh
Corrections Officers it's just it's
tough to
recruit um we see
about and this is this is something that
the council needs to address moving
forward and it was part of the leak uh
discussion and uh we're trying to find
kind of Middle Ground around here uh but
the governor uh directed us to really
look hard at the part-time police
certification program and um you know
really try to decide whether that's
something that we should continue or
whether we should eliminate a lot of
States eliminated their part-time
certification program in the wake of the
most uh recent wave of police
reform and uh at the same time as a
former police chief of a smaller agency
uh I and particularly sensitive and and
so is the council relative to these much
smaller agencies that rely on that
part-time help we're only seeing
about 10 to 12 recruits per session for
a part uh part-time police academy and
um
nonetheless uh even with 10 or 12 uh we
still have to run the academy and and it
takes resources it takes uh
uh people to teach the programs uh we do
still do you know firearms and driving
program and so it it it's still a drain
on the resources we're not getting as
much uh return on that investment again
because we're not filling the class it
would be much more efficient if we could
put you know 30 40 people in a program
like that and run it uh we do see
uh you hate to call them kids because
they're not kids they're signing up for
a dangerous job but Young people that
are you know 18 20 years old and uh we
have seen people who have literally had
other careers and uh have retired from
those initial careers and then have come
back uh to serve as a New Hampshire law
enforcement officer uh people that are
in their uh 50s uh I want to say that a
couple of classes ago we had somebody
who was over the age of 60 and candidly
outperformed uh physically and and
academically a whole lot more than
uh some of their class members um uh but
we we do see uh a lot of diversity with
regard to age uh fair amount with gender
we we have U uh we see more uh female uh
recruits coming through our doors and uh
and I would say you know
um it's hopefully the pendulum is
swinging back and people are are going
to be excited and committed to public
service and to serve our state uh as a
as a law enforcement officer so
hopefully those numbers will increase
and just one last thing around the Lea
going back to that
um some years ago there
were conversations fairly contentious
conversations about confidentiality of
policemen who are on certain lists um
and whether or not the public should
have access to who they are um some of
it was this is not a reliable person in
the court system and I mean there are a
whole lot of issues can you just speak
to the current um flavor or discussions
around those issues of confidentiality
for a policeman who's had a misconduct
Al allegation thank you for that
question
I I'll say that it the the answer is a
bit complicated in the first instance
uh in the first instance there was a
list a long time ago it was referred to
as the Lor list and that Lorry list uh
contained names of police officers that
had been put on by their uh Chiefs
because their Chiefs felt that there was
some kind of a exculpatory issue uh that
would need to be brought up uh and
revealed to a defense attorneys during
trial uh and uh the truth was that at
the time there was not a lot of guard
rails or standards that were set that
would have provided provided uniform due
process uh or uh uniform definitions of
what would put you on the list it was
almost kind of a uh you know whatever
the chief felt I think that's important
let me put you on the list uh in some
cases uh my understanding is that some
officers were placed on the list and
they didn't even know they were put on
the list so that so I think one of the
steps uh that has been
taken is uh the old lawal list which is
now referred to as the sculp uh the
exculpatory list right um the
EES
uh that uh that is now uh through the uh
the AG's office there's now a process by
which if you were on that old list uh
you are entitled to um be heard in court
uh in in Supreme Court uh relative to
whether you really should be on the list
or
not in the meantime leak uh created a
different way to address allegations of
misconduct and and candidly we're very
proud of how this came to be because
really uh through the conduct Review
Committee under RSA
106 L uh we defined statutorily what
misconduct was uh which means it also
helps Define what it isn't uh and so
everybody has a uni formed definition of
what misconduct is uh secondly uh that
law also really uh provided for a very
uniform application of due process and
fairness across the board so that the
process uh allow due process to the
officer and it also uh provided a very
objective way to take on these
complaints from citizens right that need
to be
addressed uh and finally uh there was a
law passed that said that uh there it's
kind of a reduction in the exculpatory
evidence schedule the EES where Chiefs
may put their people on uh check that
the AG's office may continue to maintain
a list uh in the meantime under RSC
106l uh we are now required
statutorily on a sustained finding that
the allegation was appropriate that um
it met the definition of misconduct and
the investigation uh had enough facts to
prove the case Beyond a
preponderance uh they're entitled to
have a hearing in front of the police
standards and training Council on the
merits of the case and then uh are also
allowed to be heard on the the
disposition or penalty uh phase uh that
we would publicly uh publish those
sustained findings on our
website and so in essence that is is
kind of the list that is going to take
over uh to the list that you spoke to uh
representative Murray and that's the old
Lori list uh also known as the
exculpatory evidence schedule uh and
that may or may not uh continue that's
under the AG uh but in the meantime this
public finding under the police stand
and training Council rules uh does uh
mandate that we uh provide that list to
the
public thank you for all the updates and
and represent
papovich thank you Mr chair I doo have a
list uh which as it happens kind of dove
tailes in with what we were talking
about uh could you start by telling us
uh you know when you look at a for me
necessary statute to rule changes I'm
looking at changes to definition of
police misconduct and whatnot you were
mentioning later in your presentation
that this was supposed to be a b but
then it was done under hb2 could you
help me understand what those changes
are and why they're not going through
the uh normal legislative process other
than the governor's office requesting
that uh thank you sir for that question
uh really the
um
the we'll address the biggest uh piece
to that first and that is that uh the
conduct Review Committee
uh check
that check that
the accreditation program was
established through executive
order and uh spelled out how the uh
accreditation committee would be formed
uh what their uh scope of responsibility
was all of that was contained in
executive order and and really all we're
trying to do is capture that executive
order in statute at this point um again
we were uh initially told to pursue
those changes through hb2 at our first
presentation uh I was directed uh by uh
a member of that committee uh Senator
gray to uh not pursue it through hb2 and
to instead uh find somebody to uh put
forth
legislation uh introduce it through a
bill uh and I did exactly that um and
was able to um uh work with
representative Terry Roy who introduced
House Bill
777 and
778 at the same time I reached back out
to the governor's office and advised
them that I had been directed by the go
by the uh Senator gray to uh make those
changes and the governor's office and
representative Roy uh both uh felt that
that uh they would pursue these two
initiatives uh on both sides both
through hb2 and to continue the
legislative process uh I have since uh
testified in front of uh the criminal
justice committee on uh 777 and
778 uh the committee voted unanimously
to support
778 uh they were ready to vote uh for SE
uh check that 777 uh they were ready to
vote on 778 uh but I did have to ask for
an oral amendment to be made uh which
really did not change the
the make a material change to it was
very slight change uh they were prepared
to vote on it but because of that oral
Amendment they had to uh uh bring it
back once it was
written
um if I may jump in for a sec I'm sorry
sir if I may jump in for a sec and I
appreciate the color information the
background I think we're in a good place
in terms of my question because this is
going through a normal legislative
process in is in in front of the
committee the decision whether a bill
adopted on the house floor you know goes
back to the house floor after Finance or
hb2 is a finance decision but I did want
to make sure really that we went through
a full legislative hearing process and
everybody had an opportunity to speak
and so on and so forth so that seems to
you know be in place so don't worry
we'll wait for those bills to be
incoming our way and keep in mind uh the
you know color information that you
provided so I I appreciate that thank
you um and if I may change gears and go
back to numbers a little bit Oh by all
means oh sorry I apolog just the help of
those two bills the 777 which is the
accreditation commission that has passed
and that is on to the Senate 778
relative to the details that Amendment
has already passed to that I think the
director was referring to and that bill
has passed and will be going to the
Senate so house position on both of
those bills has been set they are not
second committee bills so uh in
reference to the what the governor has
in her trailer Bill relative to the
details this committee could have the
decision of um removing it and letting
House Bill 778 just run its course or
amending the trailer Bill house bill to
to align exactly with what the house
passed because you would want to pass
conflicting legislation so that's a
decision for this committee I know but
bills what would be our rationale for
putting them in hb2 since they never
were formally presented to finance I
appreciate the governor's point of view
and the suggestions but it would be
interesting to justify that particular
approach wouldn't
it that would be up to the committee to
justify that approach it's not uh
unprecedented that a bill will pass
separately and then also be incorporated
into House Bill 2 for various reasons
you go ahead yeah thank you so my
original plan had a lot of numbers
involved so um I'm going to start from
the top I'm looking at your
Administration and standards uh line8
you know Department
8980 and and I'm looking at the uh P say
again p uh page number 1182 at the very
bottom of page
1182 so I'm looking for that particular
entity you have a significant increase
in personal services
permanent but for the same division you
appear to go from 12 to lose a position
so basically I'm seeing one less
position but an additional 150,000 in
compensation could you help me stand
absolutely thank you for the question I
I moved positions to where they were
more appropriate within the agency under
that um uh accounting head so if uh for
instance we had someone who belonged
under uh accreditation which would be
under um Administration and standards I
moved them out of training and so that
was just moving positions around to
where they're more appropriate for
funding I understand I mean I looked at
your bottom line and Essen your total
number of positions for the entire
organization is flat so I get that you
are moving people around I'm just
curious why you know people got Mo a
person got moved out but 150k in
additional compensation got moved in I
would have expected that if you decrease
the positions I'll see a drop so I I
don't want to be overly detailed but
150k increase with one less person in
there is uh something that's worth I
believe we move two positions around I I
don't have the specifics right if we
could provide that later that would be
great I I I would appreciate it because
again it's a biggish number change there
i' like to understand and um on the next
page um I see a significant drop in uh
on page 1183 line 024 maintenance other
than building grounds it drops by about
2/3 I'm assuming it's part of the
overall attempt to control cost but I
don't want to make assumptions I'd
rather uh understand thank you for the
question this is the the answer that I
give to representative Murray which is
that we had had our records management
software in an inappropriate class which
was a so it's covered under that moved
it onto software and created a new line
in
software okay so to make sure I fully
understand um in the past while the
amounts were budgeted for grounds we
used the ability to move funds around to
deal with other priorities and now we're
just moving them into the budget so we
need to so we decrease the need to just
transfer in between different funds yes
just moving it to the appropriate place
where software belongs and you'll notice
that if you look at the 038 line you'll
see it went from Z to
206,000 and then in 27 to 27,000 that is
for our records management software
guess what my next question was going to
be yeah yes so that is the uh Records
management yes sir and any other
additional software that it does not
cover for us and is that
a it looks to be recurring right is that
a new B basically because it's a new
thing do you have any startup costs or
is that the operational budget going
forward thank you for your question uh
we we had a software called Benchmark
and we were uh using the state contract
for software on an annual basis but they
were not suiting all of our needs for
officer record management and they were
charging us very large increases each
year so we went through an elaborate RFP
process this last year and did a lot of
research and we have a new contract
that's a six-year contract that was
signed by governor and Council and
approved and we just finished all of
that and we have a much better rate of
of what we're paying and so what you're
seeing is that is the cost of the
contract for each year that was recently
approved by Governor Council great and
uh do you know cuz I don't know your
budget well enough where are the costs
that were you know reduced the ones that
you used to pay that were increasing all
the time CU this goes from zero to this
right so where was the stuff that we
replaced it should be noted that um we
we did have to engage the uh vendor that
we getting ready to step away from y uh
at the same time that we had to engage
the services of the new vendor so that
we did not uh in any way interrupt our
our operational needs uh so there may be
a little bit of blip with of increase
over the this uh remaining uh budget
cycle just it'll reflect paying both
those uh vendors and then in the new
fiscal year uh that uh the old vendor we
will no longer be engag so we are
overlapping for this entire budget cycle
no sir just uh since uh the Inception
of uh the new contract and uh when did
the old
contract June 30th of this
year so we we uh we did have to extend a
contract that we had with Benchmark I'm
completely fine with overlapping because
again you cannot flip a switch and flip
to the other you got to be safe in
transitioning I get that I was just
trying to identify you know I see the
increases I was looking for the matching
decreases and again it can be something
that you guys follow up with if uh you
know but again when you increase by 200
and call it
30k and you tell me that hey we were
paying way more and we were getting high
increases I understand that you're
getting additional functionality and
therefore you may end up paying more
overall and get a better value but I'd
like to see where the you know old
software being place is dropping from
the budget so that I can see how much
you really increase or decrease versus
the functionality so if we could have
that uh you know breakdown provided and
if it's not right now in the budget you
know tiny forecast of what will happen
when once that contract drops off the
books yes sir I I'm I guess I'm not
understanding where you're seeing 234
what what I'm looking at the lines uh 37
and
38 um 2
25,27 rounded
in on page 1183 technology Hardware line
3738 under Administration and standards
so basically they add up to
232 rounded for
2026 and I was asking I see the new
contract coming in I want you to see
where the old contract that you are
replacing is and when it will go away so
you can see that if you look at class 24
y fy2 adjusted adjusted author
authorized was
19150 right that was the price of the
contract with the current vendor okay so
that was the one that we are we are now
paying 206 next year for the first year
of the contract with the new vendor I
got it so I should look at those two
lines combined for now just to
understand the totals and the drops and
I got it thank you so much yes sir I
hope I answered your question no no you
did and U it's just there are a lot of
little details so um if I may
so the next uh one I'm assuming um we
have something similar on line 47 on
line
47 hang on I got to line this up
correctly line 48 contractual
Maintenance building grounds goes from
250 yes representative thank you for
your question and this is what I had
mentioned to representative Murray
earlier which is we have aoral Services
contract now okay which was a cost
savings from our two full-time positions
that we great thank you thank you and
we've already covered
this
1186 you have
equipment uh sorry on line 30 equipment
new
replacement you have a significant
amount of expenditures in 2026 it goes
from 40,000 in 25 to
114 I'm assuming that may be related to
but uh representative you may notice
that in the actual fiscal 2024 to
adjusted 2025 the same kind of I know
High first year second I know but it
would be good to understand why the
it so it's basically the line where it
goes uh as my colleague was pointing out
from 92,000 in24 to 1425 then to 114 and
then back to
24 yes representative thank you for your
question so in our efficiency Budget on
page 4202 of our efficiency budget
request for class 30 equipment The
increased funds were needed to replace a
recruit training uh utility vehicle for
training purposes and then also to put
into service our what we call skid car
that teaches recruits how to drive a
vehicle in a skid um and that that is
what the increase was for thank you so
much and um I'm all said thank you Mr
chairman I appreciate it by the way
thank
you I appreciate the question thank you
others representative haen Phillips I
just wanted to go back to the um your
presentation page two about the form e
necessary statutes or rule changes
section um does that correlate with our
previous discussion about the you know
the former Lori list to the to the more
updated list through the AG's office or
matter uh thank you for the question uh
Madam just uh so that I understand
uh the
uh the question is related to requesting
clarification in definition of policeman
conduct
these were um very minor uh changes
under the definition of misconduct uh
literally to put the word
or in between uh certain sections uh and
and did not um really speak uh to any
material changes of what police
so this is just going to be part of hb2
suggestion or or is it not included
currently and you're asking us to
include it I guess I'm
confused I apologize I do not uh have uh
the level of knowledge to understand
sometimes when we're talking about uh
some of the pathways but in essence uh
that is uh an hb2 amendment uh just to
words what you're requesting of us it
the governor did not include it into hb2
understanding the only item in the
governor's trailer bill is relative to
the details that we talked about the
this section is not I do see it in the
uh submission for the the necessary rule
changes statute changes from the agency
phase but it does not appear the
government
put those in her trailer Bill nor I
don't think those are covered in 777 or
778 so and you're making note of that as
well and and that would be up to a
member of this I know it's up to us but
are you making a note of it so we can so
I'll remember sure if you yeah if you
want to uh ask the uh Council or uh
others for language specific to what
they're looking for here we could draft
an amendment to
consider can you provide that language I
think it is in their agency budget
request so we could probably pull from
that
thank you sir representative hacken
continue you have another
question are there others I think under
the requested government uh Governor's
recommended budget um there seem to be
other items there that you were looking
for as to make an amendment for hb2 um
all those line
changes this part Mickey
yes page three so this requested change
to the governor's recommended budget
would be in section one of house bill
one so this is where uh they are
requesting to unfund a position so we
would reduce class 10 class 60
Associated costs with that position and
put all that in transfers to di doit so
they could fund the position there so I
do have a question about that I did
understand what was going on there um
did you request this during the governor
phase
I think that uh initially we did and
then uh we spoke with uh the
commissioner of the uh
doit and
uh he suggested that we uh pursue uh
this pathway instead uh to to fill that
position we were initially going to hire
just a a person to come in and do it
work and uh commissioner goule felt it
was more important to make sure that
that person was uh part of
doit uh so that they could kind of speak
hand in glove with regard to State
security issues and and um uh making
sure that that they're working within
the framework of what doit uh wanted
them to do so essentially the governor's
budget director never heard about this
Staffing we may have missed the window
for that and and in fact that is correct
the okay yes just want to understand
what was what was happening there thank
you yes
other I guess I'm I'm just wanting to I
think you know the your these little
formal requests are reasonable um I'm
trying to understand what do you need
from us with regards to amendments um to
address some of these
things can I answer that so I'll work I
I'll work with the police than so they
they do have uh some uh statutory
requests here most of which are covered
in House Bill 778 and 777 which like I
said have passed I'll work with police
standards to come up with an amendment
that would cover everything else for the
committee to consider at a later
time thank you
sir re
papovich thank you Mr chair and again
thank you I was looking at your uh
personal service uh temporary appointed
uh lines all over and um for the lack of
a better word they're a bit lumpy if you
look at on page
1186 every one of these will be line 050
because that's what the temporary
Personnel is you have basically a big
increase in 2025 and every every other
year is about 200 something thousand
less and I looked at all the other lines
to see if you guys are moving people
around and uh the only change that I see
that's comparable in size is on page
1183 where you are
increasing that
line in the new budget year but it's
only an increase of about 50 or
something oh sorry never mind I you're
increasing it by about 100 so can you
help me understand I know that you were
talking earlier about the need to run a
bunch ofies because you had a lot of uh
you know vacancies and you needed to
train way more officers than usual is
that related to that what you know what
gives because again when a line goes
from 445 to 675 and then back to 455 and
472 again that's on page 1186 line
050 I think it's worth understanding
on I don't think we have the same page
number as you do so I'm working on it
it's in your um hang on I'll give you
the exact numbers it's
0687 so it's
050 page number in my big book is
1186 but again page numbers in the big
help right it's temporary staff for the
unit yeah instead of numbers I could
have also told you the words sorry
former
accountant you'll see that again it's
445 in 2024
675 in 25 and then it drops back to 456
years I know but transfers transfers
would have to more or less match
MoneyWise this is more than transfers
one possibility just keep in mind that
actual 24 is actually what was spent not
the budgeted amount okay and when that
happens um 25 adjusted authorized the
leftover from 24 can actually flow into
the 25 adjusted authoriz and correct me
I'm wrong this Mickey but um you can't
just look at those as the budgeted the
original budgeted amounts that is that
is correct for adjusted authorized if if
it is a
non-aps uh account it could carry into
the following year plus remember uh 25
adjusted authorized may also include any
transfers that they made at fiscal or
any additional money that was accepted
or or moved from from elsewhere uh like
the employee pay raise that happened two
years ago would have been something
added onto this when you compare the
last budget I understand it's something
that may not be answerable right now but
some details I believe what you may be
seeing is we were allocated some funding
at the beginning of this bium for
part-time court security officer salary
50 which we would no longer have so I
think we we had a bump in and it was uh
appropriated through the banum from year
to year to to non-lps but then will
lapse so that may be what you're seeing
as we were given some funding to start
that security program sounds like it
would explain some of it thank you and
if we could just you know look into it
and follow up just to make sure we
understand again I understand that a lot
of these questions require you to go
back and crunch numbers and uh you know
see exactly what's going on and I would
appreciate I appreciate the you know
work you'll have to put into it but we
really need to understand what's going
on it's a tough budget year and we
really need to look at every U little
sir okay I have a few questions
good
here you talked about the part-time
training classes potentially being
eliminated if I understood
your conversation accurately and my
question there is what savings would
to it's
indeterminable only because
uh I would I would have to we would have
to sit down and kind of peel back the
onion a little bit to see how many of
those classes during that part-time
academ are taught specifically by our
people uh as opposed to uh pulling in
volunteers to come in and teach portions
of that uh we would also need to look at
um uh those resources that we're using
to include the firing range the driving
pad uh and and any other uh kind of
expendable uh costs uh that would be
related to to uh that
program could you do that just um really
what I'm looking for is order of
magnitude not necessarily down to the
penny kind of thing sure I'm just to
give an idea of what what savings might
generate and if you want to follow up
when you're doing that with in terms of
the pros and cons as you were starting
to express them here in terms of it
sounded like you were leaning towards
maybe you would consider um reducing
that eliminating that I should
say and if I misunderstood that please
correct
me oh no sir chair the uh uh that is
very much a discussion that needs to be
had uh among the council members and uh
the council would ultimately determine
whether that program should continue or
not okay um you we also I believe as on
M you talked about the crisis training
and you talked about a special non-aps
fund I'm guessing that's a dedicated
fund that is correct can you provide us
with
no I apologize absolutely go ahead it
was it was I wish I had the RSA in front
um yeah it was continuously appropriated
Mickey it was Senate Bill 376 from 2022
that appropriated $1.1 million when it
established the crisis intervention
training that appropriation 1.1 million
was
non-aps what last budget we also
appropriated in the operating budget
another $1.1 million in 24 and in
25 I would not say that those
Appropriations are non-aps but I feel
perhaps it's been that way so we would
want to I just want to confirm that with
admin services and police standards
whatever Direction This committee wants
to go in um we would clarifi I I would
suggest we clarify those Appropriations
whether they're lapsing or
non-aps could you also clarify how if we
don't call it a dedicated fund it's got
to be somewhere
and it is it's carried in that account
as just Balan forward essentially it's
just I would I'm not necessarily sure
what was appropriated in house bill one
last bium should have carried forward or
if it should have lapsed I get it I just
so we'll we'll work with I can work with
police standards on that and then um and
I would say if it's the intention of
police standards to carry out that
program for the next two years they
could use that fund those funds that are
available without having to appropriate
more money as you can see in the
governor's budget there's not more money
added but it it appears to me like there
is money available for them to carry
forward for the next bium and and maybe
they could speak more on that and if I
may I believe there's approximately
800,000 left in the non-aps funds that
we could use to continue the CIT
program for what the statute laid out
which was one person from each agency
the reimbursement costs associated with
that thank
you and as a
if if I may chair uh as a practical
matter it's important to also recognize
that uh while we provide the CIT
training to get that Staffing the way
we're supposed to uh be addressing
through legislation uh we also have
Recruitment and Retention issues and so
we might put somebody through that
training for that police department and
then they leave the business and so
where uh it's there's never a time where
we can check the box and say okay we've
actually you know succeeded in uh the
legislator's uh mandate uh because we're
we're just kind of chasing our tail to
to provide that training as needed uh
recognizing that people are retiring or
business so there is as I understand it
and I don't know they are say in front
of me a
$100,000 amount I think annually but
maybe it's by anually from the asset
forfeiture fund are you familiar with
this could you speak to that and so we
were mandated by uh the
legislature to uh provide a funding
source uh to uh reimburse police
agencies to subject new police officers
to
psychological uh testing screening to
make sure that they are uh not
exhibiting uh psychological issues that
would prevent them from working in law
enforcement uh many agencies that were
not State agencies at the time the the
the statute basically said if you work
for a state law enforcement
agency you shall uh have a ssite test
and we strongly recommend if you work
for a municipal or County agency that
you get a sitech test because that kind
of turned into an unfunded mandate there
was a lot of agencies that just could
not cover the cost of making sure that
um uh they were getting screened
psychologically and so ultimately uh
that carve out that came from the AG's
office the the uh asset forfeiture
account uh is specifically used to
provide reimbursement to any police
agency in the State uh to cover the cost
of the psychological screening which is
now mandated in RSA
106l so just to clarify so specifically
to nonstate
entities that is correct sir thank you
very
much okay any
other questions comments
any other comments you all would like to
make we would just like to thank all of
you for for your time and letting us uh
uh you know present our our situation
here well thank you both very much
you're we definitely gave you a lot of
questions and you guys are very good to
handle them as well as you did so we
appreciate that oh yes of course you do
representative Murray go ahead but but
it's a fun
one where do our people go for canine
training because you don't do the
training here and I'm just C I'm just
I'm just I find the whole thing
fascinating so I have all these little
questions I like so where do they go for
K9 uh so uh a lot of can9 units in the
state of New Hampshire uh will uh
participate in uh what they call npac uh
training and nesac is the Northern New
England State Police uh Network and so
uh a lot of Municipal uh K9 units will
you know maybe travel to Massachusetts
to go through their program Boston has a
very very strong can9 program as well
and um and there is a state Association
of can9 officers uh and and uh they also
put on training as well so um it's a
tremendous uh training it's very
esoteric you know you really have to be
a be a can9 Handler to be able to
deliver that kind of training have that
that expertise to to uh train others uh
and candidly that's that's outside of
our bandwidth we just don't have that I
went with officer Frank Frankie and all
he did was growl at me the whole
[Laughter]
time maybe you shouldn't
self-incriminate
here so that's we going to follow up on
the asset forer thing is that $100,000 a
year a bium that's $100,000 uh per year
okay and is that the words you used to
describe what it does for the or what
the test doing is that in statute the
the uh testing yeah yes that is in uh
RSA 106 L sh I believe it's
four
uh I believe it's
four chapter four and it speaks directly
to uh a um site
test and a a medical exam with a drug
screen we also want to uh make sure that
uh new recruits are being screened for
any kind of drug use okay thank you I'm
sorry to push you on that but I have
somebody's ask me about it and I want to
be able to tell them exactly what it's
for so they don't push me to delete
it so thank you I appreciate that
absolutely sir and thank you for being
here you've been fantastic thank you
appreciate so any
other things the committee wants to get
into before we get back together again
this afternoon
oh go
nck I wait we'll wait for you take your
time so we have uh three bills with one
Amendment this afternoon at one yes okay
that's the plan yes I'm actually uh I
didn't speak with Eileen I had spoken
with well at least
with with representative hacken phis but
also with Kate with representative
Murray um regarding 677 which is the EP
pen Bill uh there's an amendment which I
sent out um we'll get a slightly
modified version of that and both Erica
Leon representative Lon and
representative uh Drago thank you um
will be here to um describe it it is a
bill to pass on consent and I think
we'll understand from them that it
shouldn't cost anything to any of the
locals which would mean I would think if
we all agree that we could just pass it
right on through and and and not have to
worry about it
um another bill that that I believe I
spoke them both about um was a a Judy
Aron bill which we passed last term that
allocated 25,000 didn't allocate allowed
a community to Quest up to $25,000 in
catastrophic G if you will that sort of
thing and that is now law and this bill
increases that threshold to $100,000 but
you may have also noticed that the it's
not a general funds bill it's a specific
fund Bill and that fund has $40,000 on
it so it's not really hit to our general
funds and I'm inclined if you all agree
to just also let that pass through and
see where it goes the fund has 40,000 in
it now correct so it's we tough to get
to
100 so at some point I'm sure they'll
come back for more money but for now
this is and the third one um I can't
remember what it's about but my thinking
is to retain it and talk about it when
we actually get to the budget that's
thank you the the young the youth the
youth transition thing yeah exact well
the other two have just rather soon get
out of here that's okay oh yeah fine
pass them through okay and they just
keep the retain the one that's about the
driver's license so heads up when you
talk about I'm not asking for
commitments I just want to tell you
where I'm
headed good then I will um adjourn the
1113 maybe we should hold on until
Mickey comes back before officially
maybe I'll not yet adjourn it if you
haven't already shut down the cameras
and I'll wait for our LBA adviser to
you
e
so if you're still there we're
officially closed finance division 2
otherwise if you closed it earlier that
too
e
all right so um M being
107 106 uh I'll open the finance
division
2 work session and we'll start with um
HB number
one65 relative to the maximum amount of
disaster relief funding provided to
municipalities after a natural
disaster and was okay with everyone I'll
uh yeah thank you Aaron to come up and
uh I kept wanted to say Judy and I knew
that wasn't right unless you say bunch
and
Judy and please let us know who you are
and uh and give us your take on your
bill thank you thank you for the record
my name is representative Judy Aaron I
represent the uh Sullivan County
District 4 which are the towns of aworth
Washington and and I'm introducing this
bill HB 165 to you this
afternoon relative to the maximum amount
of disaster relief funding provided to
municipalities after a natural disaster
I'm here to correct a wrong that was
made last year when the language of this
RSA was included in a bill s SP 499 that
went to Committee of conference and some
of you were even present at that the
original Bill language s sought for up
to $100,000 to possibly be awarded to a
municipality after a natural disaster
hits their Community the
Senate excuse me the Senate was adamant
that the governor would not sign the
bill unless the amount was lowered to
25,000 so it was agreed upon that we
would settle for a severe reduction in
this kind of Grant in order to get
language signed into law that would
provide for a statutory vehicle for the
state to get money to municipality in
need in an expedient
manner I'm simply asking with this bill
that the original $100,000 Grant amount
be reestablished because we all know
that $25,000 is hardly disaster relief
to any Community it barely helps at all
to pay to fix roads temporarily or to be
used to help to get community running
again after severe flooding or other
natural disasters hit the the bill also
corrects some language that Homeland
Security emergency management suggested
so that it is clear that disaster relief
funding received by this grant program
only applies to this program and is not
confused with any other disaster relief
funding that a municipality may
specifically happens on line five in the
bill
where it says in grant money quote from
year um this is very important change to
this language this language needs to be
changed and it needs to be passed so
some of you know that I've been working
on this legislation since severe
flooding hit aworth and other towns in
the state in July 2021 and again in July
2023 many towns experience flooding due
to heavy rains and just so you know the
bills that we have passed already in
2022 and 2023 for disaster relief loans
s SP 409 and the state share of payment
on non- FEMA reimbursable expenditures s
sp402 have not even been accessible or
functional to our
municipalities let's not leave this work
undone for another year if a disaster
hits we as a state need to be prepared
to help our municipal ities and give
them quick and useful tools to be able
to make roads passable and deal with the
emergencies especially if they do not
have the financial resources available
I'd be happy to answer any questions and
I've also provided additional
information regarding problems with S SP
402 and S SP
409 um I have a packet to hand out to
everybody if you if you'd be so kind
which includes um the testimony and also
uh background information about where we
are with S sp42 and S sp49 I also
provided the committee with a packet of
information that was a a report that was
done by the Pew um Foundation about how
States pay for disaster relief it's a
very interesting read and unfortunately
New Hampshire is
woefully behind in what we ought to be
doing to help our municipal ities should
a disaster strike and that's all I have
I'd be happy to answer any
questions there any questions sure go
ahead um for the record just um so you
know to make sure we all understand a
little bit more about the history can
you speak to I think two things one is
that your town was pretty much left to
or towns are left to their own resources
here because they're not state roads
that there's a difference between what
the state do with the state road but
where a town is left to its own devices
correct and also can you all go over
just you know very briefly uh I remember
we're concerned last time about how this
would potentially have a negative impact
on your ability to get FEMA funds can
you just give us the narrative to say
how you're protected from you know some
of the FEMA issues correct
okay so let my town is still struggling
to get roads fixed I have a bridge
there's a bridge at the
on one on Forest Road um it's a
municipal
bridge that bridge was damaged in 2023
flooding we won't get that bridge fixed
until
2027 so that thoroughfare is out so just
to put it in context I mean there are
roads in our town that are still unable
to be repaired uh in an expedient Manner
and try as we may to you know put money
aside if you don't have the tax base to
deal with it it's a problem if you have
a smaller town um that the tax base
already struggles with just maintaining
have so so there is a problem with our
smaller municipalities being able to
recover and absorb the costs of these
devastating floods and natural
disasters and so far as um money given
to the town as a grant and how that may
or may not interfere with FEMA funding I
know that there have been um you know
rules are being looked at in FEMA to be
able to make some
exceptions um they are um you know we
have an instance where now the town has
we have on our Warren articles coming up
in aworth um where FEMA has said okay
well um we have Ro we have money that's
been appropriated and set aside for this
particular repair but we know that this
other repair is something that's more of
a priority and we just need permission
from your town to be able to move those
funds so so you can see that FEMA is
pretty much um you know they're they're
willing to work with a community to be
able to um move funds where it needs to
be done and I think that you know even
if you receive grant money for uh
certain temporary repairs that those
temporary repairs may be something that
the town can absorb and wouldn't need
FEMA to um to come in and and and do a
project on um so I don't I don't think
that it would really necessarily
interfere with any money that a town uh
anybody
else on hacking Phillips yeah thank you
Mr chair thank you representative Aaron
for being with us today um I'm looking
at the fiscal note um for the for the
bill and um just not noting here for the
record that the current balance as of
June 30th 2024 for the two funds that
might be applicable to this
bill uh so the New Hampshire emergency
response Recovery Fund is currently a
zero balance and the New Hampshire
disaster relief F fund will be
4,292 and there are no Appropriations
currently included in the bill could you
speak to the maybe future impact that
this bill could have sure um so in many
discussions that I've had with chairman
Wier um he indicated to me that because
of the way this is set up that a town a
municipality can come to fiscal
committee and request certain funding
that the money doesn't have to be parked
in a fund anywhere that if when a
municipality comes to fiscal and makes a
Rec request that what fiscal can do is
then say oh well do we have any
unappropriated funds somewhere or can we
take money out of the rainy day fund to
satisfy a request and again a request
doesn't have to be from fiscal committee
doesn't have to be
$100,000 it can be a partial amount of
what the municipality is seeking so but
what he indicated to me was that instead
of having money specifically earmarked
and parked into a fund that the fiscal
committee could move funds around to
satisfy a request that that a town comes
to it
with just to be clear the fiscal
committee definitely cannot take money
out of the r to day fund okay I'm pretty
certain of that um and as far as moving
funds around I guess that might depend
on the situation sure Micky so I can
clarify and the department can speak to
this too when they come up what
representative Aaron referred to earlier
as far as the assistance for
municipality to apply for a half of the
nonfederal match or the non-federal
portion of FEMA there is an open warrant
and statute for that uh relative to uh
RSA but not to the r day fund to the
general fund to the general fund correct
uh under RSA 21p 37e this additional
disaster relief that this this is
looking to increase from 25 to 100,000
this would come from that disaster fund
that's identified in 21p 46 and 46a
there's no open warrant for those funds
those would be subject to just whatever
they have available and that's the
$45,000 so there I I don't see a a
mechanism
to get additional General funds drawn
for this purpose and the department can
speak to that or if I'm misinterpreting
it so what I was under the understanding
was
that um from speaking with represent uh
chairman Wier was that monies could be
moved around if need be in a disaster
where as prior to this language being in
statute there was absolutely no statut
mechanism at all for the state to be
able to give money to a municipality so
that's kind of why why we did
this thank
you is there anybody else wanted to
speak to I yes one other thing I also
did want to say about um the language
that was passed for the 50% match
is that those have not even the rules
for that M that program have not even
gotten in gotten established and so I
mean my town is still waiting for the
rules to be established they're waiting
for up to
$200,000 in funds to be released from
the
state for that
program and the department is here to
speak to that I think it is still in the
rulem process and they could probably
update the committee on
sure so who is here from the department
who wants
you good afternoon Mr chairman uh Rob
buckton director Homeland Security and
Emergency Management for the State of
New
Hampshire please go ahead my my only
comment is regarding the 50% match that
is still in Ru making uh and it is with
legal so we're in the process of
developing the rules regarding this
piece of legislation particularly we
don't have a position uh one way or the
other thank you any questions from the
committee represent papovich if I may
just because I'm not aware of the
timelines of that do you have any idea
how long will it take until the rules
will be finalized and relief can be
provided I Know It's tricky to answer
those questions but any kind of ballpark
yeah so so the rule set is in draft form
it's with the Department of Safety legal
team right now
once it comes from there then it'll go
hearing any other questions I don't know
what the time the date would be on that
only everybody good thank you very much
for your time and effort to come here
appreciate
that are there others
who want to say anything about this okay
raining i' i' go with OTP if you're
something look like you're dying to say
something over
there whenever you're ready uh
representative Roy the Roy
yes yes okay rep Bean yes rep droy yes
rep Murray yes rep hackin Phillips
yes Kelly
okay all right Sor I'm little behind the
6 all righty
so and open HB 612
enabling the Division of Motor Vehicles
to create a temporary traditional
driver's license for youth operators
about to turn
21 and I would ask who is here who might
want to discuss that yes ma'am please
come forward and introduce yourself and
thoughts thank you very very much Mr
chair and thank you committee for
listening uh my name is Stephanie grund
I represent Hillsboro 34 from Amherst
and I'm here for representative veu who
is unfortunately in London on vacation
with his
family um but under current law the
youth operators face um some unne
unnecessary challenges um approaching
their 21st birthday in particular if
their birthday falls on a weekend
holiday um or if they want to renew
their license
online uh youth operators who wish to
renew online receive a horizontal
license must also wait until their 21st
birthday to do so if they renew even one
day early they receive a vertical
license and they face the same
inconvenience of returning to the DMV
later additionally renewing online
involves a waiting period while the
license is printed and mailed leaving
drivers without legal proof of renewal
at that
time the inefficient process wastes time
for drivers and increases the workload
for the DMV staff this bill provides a
simple and practical solution it allows
youth operators submit their renewal
application up to 30 days before their
21st birthday and they receive a
temporary license that's valid for
driving purposes this temporary license
ensures they can transition seamlessly
to the standard horizontal license on or
shortly after their birthday regardless
of whether their birthday falls on a
weekday weekend or a holiday so first
the bill eliminates unnecessary trips to
the DMV drivers can submit their
application online and they receive the
license they prefer saving time and
frustration second it reduces the burden
on the DMV staff by cutting down on
duplicate license requests making
operations more efficient and third it
costs it's there was a cost-effective
solution the one-time system update will
cost approximately
$48,000 and it'll streamline the process
for years years to come so uh that's a
quick brief introduction and I'm happy
to try and answer any questions and I
know there's the DMV staff who's here to
answer as well thank you uh any
questions from the committee
representative hacken Phillips um I just
wanted to thank representative grun for
being here and um just to notify the
committee that the prime sponsor shared
in an attachment with me that I've just
emailed out to you all um for just the
um couple of talking points that
represent of previously mentioned but a
few extra points so um if you have a
moment check your email you'll see that
there thank
you anybody else
questions thank thank you for taking the
time to come and you're welcome B
appreciate
it and I'm guessing maybe someone from
sir thank you both you could rep uh
represent introduce yourselves and
proceed thank you thank you Mr chair uh
John morasco director of the DMV and
Jennifer Bailey assistant director of
the
DMV want to thank uh representative
grund for that overview was fantastic um
it covers uh why this bill is so
important and we want to recognize
representative Vu for uh working to make
this happen uh towards the end of last
session we had a sidebar conversation he
asked about this he wanted to come up
with a solution for it I can tell you
internally at the DMV um this has been a
topic of conversation for many years
approximately 15 and I can tell you that
being in this position for the last
three I've had more people in the
community that have come up and asked
about why did we do what your renewal
notice asks us to do which is renew
early um to get your license and then
when you do that if you have the youth
operator you're mailed the youth
operator license and that requires you
now to make an appointment to go to the
DMV to pay $10 for a duplicate license
and nobody wanted the duplicate and
yellow on the license as well um so
everything representative grunt said is
uh is exactly what the issue is so now
there's a path forward that you can
renew your license early if you're
transition positioning from the youth
operator to the horizontal license being
over AG 21 and not be impacted if it
happens to fall on a weekend or if you
come in one day early to do that and
that's been going on for a long time and
quite frankly that's affected thousands
probably tens of thousands of people uh
definitely over the last uh 15 years
that have been inconvenience with that
I've talked to some people that renewed
online got the youth operator in the
mail and never came back in to get the
horizontal license and just kept it for
another 5 years and that's not
appropriate um they deserve the
horizontal license at that point they're
21 years old so it sounds like you
support this 100 100% sir it's a great
Bill uh I couldn't couldn't say enough
about it and I think the way that it's
structured again with the uh the grace
period uh in the beginning the grace
period for the license after um and what
Jen I want to recognize Jen for doing a
great job on the fiscal note as always
and also looking at um the technology
changes to hold the queue so basically
until you turn 21 midnight that night
that's when that goes to the system and
the hard copy horizontal license is
printed and mailed but you still have
the 30-day overlap so that you're still
in good standing so it's a it's a great
Bill thank you Mr chair and again thank
you for being here and I appreciate the
efforts put into this
bill not having spent a lot of time
thinking in this space uh why do we even
ask people to apply for a horizontal
license when they turn
21 I mean seriously couldn't they just
automatically get the horizontal one or
get an email that
hey you need to drop off your vertical
to get your horizontal just come to the
DMV and it's already waiting for you I'm
just trying to understand obviously this
is an improvement yeah my question I
guess is why don't we improve it even
more and save even more time and
effort yes um so currently the way the
law is written is you have to have a
youth operator or a vertical license
until your age of 21 um so you have to
carry that until you're that age that's
why we're having this situation where
they're renewing on a weekend many of
them the the the one complaint we hear
is they want to go out to the bar on
their 21st birthday and a bar won't take
an expired license to serve you alcohol
or so that's that's the whole reasoning
behind is it gives them a way to have a
valid license to go out on their birth
date but then they don't have to then
use a under 21 vertical license for five
additional years into their 20s
understood but do all the vertical
licenses automatically expire when uh
people reach the right
age okay so okay I think that clarifies
my confusion here yeah you your first
original license if you're under the age
of 21 expires on your 21st birthday it's
pro-rated thank you I got here when I
was over 21 so uh thank you
sir other questions from the
committee so just one thing I want to
confirm um there is no appropriation so
can I assume that you all are willing to
include that just do this on your own we
did look at that sir and um for for the
one-time cost uh we would find the money
in our budget to handle it that is such
great news yeah yeah yeah thank you very
much for that and thank you very much
for your testimony if that's all you
you no pass yeah and is is there anybody
else that wanted to speak on this oh
representative
Leon hello representative Erica Leon
from dairy um I just wanted to speak to
sort of the importance about holding
this in the queue our DMV is doing a
phenomenal job turning out renewals very
quickly when I renewed I had my new one
in hand within a week so I'd like to say
they're doing a great job and this bill
is help them keep doing an even better
job thank you very
much look for a
second so we have a motion
representative Mur and a second from
representative papovich okay and let me
know when you're ready to miss okay wow
okay when you're ready you can call the
rooll on
OTP okay um representative papovich
I representative Bean yes D Roy yes
representative Murray yes representative
hackin Phillips yes representative Kelly
yes we have SE 7 to zero oh I'm sorry
not yet you CH that's a yes I know it I
knew it because you was sending me those
signals okay so the motion passed 7 to
Zer thank you
that
one if anything I'm entertaining you're
off all right so the next bill we're
going to consider is HB 677 requiring
schools to maintain a supply of EpiPen
injectors for use in event of an
emergency and I'll representative I'll
I'll rep notice rep
rep here go the names again Drago
Drago thank you and please introduce
yourself better than I
did good afternoon I'm representative
Drago I represent the town of R in New
Hampshire HB 677 passed the education
committee unanimously unanimously a few
weeks ago and then it was on the consent
calendar so I won't go into the
specifics of the details of the bill but
um Everybody kind of recognized that EP
pens are necessary in schools so I'm
here just to talk about the fiscal
impact and as of right now there
actually is no fiscal impact to the
state there's multiple programs that
actually give these out for free uh to
school districts um the old school
EpiPen uh I think it's called epipens
for schools
um you you get four free doses the thing
about epipens is it comes in um an adult
version or it comes in a junior version
depends on weight um and what's nice
about this program is it has um so it
comes in a two pack that's the other
thing about EP pens when you buy and
they come in two pack so you get two two
packs a year per school so you get to
choose or the school nurse would choose
depending on demographics of the school
uh you can do two adult two packs two
Junior two packs or of each if you
happen to be like a middle school where
you might have both weight you know
weight ratios or whatever the other
thing that's nice about this program is
if you happen to have to use one during
the school year they replace it for free
so the school does not have to purchase
epinephrine uh the other program in the
bill we added in uh FDA approved nasal
spray FDA just recently approved instead
of doing the auto injector you can
inhale uh epinephrine and um up to yep
um that's not in the bill correct the
is it's in one
spot oh I asked OLS to give either put
it in everywhere or just put it in one
spot they chose one spot but we have an
amendment just to put it after
representative Lam will'll talk about
that in a minute but we're going to add
it everywhere it says epinephrine we're
going to say FDA approved okay I see now
where you have it in there as well okay
um so right now it's called nephy
obviously you can't legislate a trade
name but
um nephie is the nasal spray right now
but it's only for 66 pounds and up so it
doesn't really qualify for Elementary
School per se they also offer the same
program you get four doses two two packs
and they also provide free
replenishments if you have the
unfortunate circumstance of having to
use one during the school year so
basically schools just get the uh
prescription go online you fill out you
know account fill it to paperwork and um
you get your epinephrine so who covers
the initial two per year is that the
feds it's through it's through a program
I I assume I I didn't trace the money
back to see if feds put in money or not
I assume it's just a good
advertising we all saw a few years ago
they were charging $600 for epinephrine
and it was like you know $2 to make or
something my guess is these companies
say well it's a tax write off and it
gives us good advertising by but I don't
really know they might get Kickbacks or
I I don't know how that part works okay
what you're understanding is that right
now the companies essentially provide
two per school and if you use one you
get you'll get a replac for free as well
four yeah there's no question about that
there's no charge for any of that yeah
no nope okay yeah well thank you y is is
it oh yeah you said it's from the
company right that's your understanding
yep yep now I don't know if they get
paid by the federal government that
doesn't really matter to me
no seems to be straight from the M okay
committee okay um are do you have other
comments oh no that was that was
basically it okay are we waiting for the
amendment so I thought we'd hear from
okay the the state since they're here
while um I believe representative L's
literally running over to OS now to get
yes the uh apparently the amendment
requesting not go through this morning
if it's not here I can pull out the
copies that say may instead of shall and
we can agree to cross out May take sh
and we'll deal with that but um if since
the state is here do you all want to
manufactured so please introduce
yourselves and take it away Melissa
white division director for learner
Support Department of
Education KY Rambo Bureau administrator
for wellness and nutrition Department of
Education
so I just would like to have
clarification
on where the
funding is supposed to be coming from
because it's not clear in the
legislation how it's written and maybe I
need to see the amendment first before
maybe that'll shed some clarity on it
but can you paiz for one
so we all have a slightly earlier
version of the amendment which he's
passing out now which is identical to
the one that I believe representative L
will bring back that replaces one word
may we shall but take take your time to
you don't have to race
through it it's a replace all bills so
you don't have to do a comparison it's a
replace all amendment I
were the responsibility for paying for
the um product where that lies because
the way that it's written it doesn't
line seven on page
two there's a dollar appropriated to the
Department of Education for the purpose
of reimbursing school districts for
maintaining supplies
of the epinephrine Auto
injectors so that's not clear that's
saying the department the state is
responsible for paying for them but then
there's information about we're getting
them for free from a company so I just
want to point
out we might want to
clarify who's responsible is it the
local level is it this company is it the
state for maintaining this Supply
actually I was hoping you were going to
clarify this so you're not familiar with
this
program no not the not the program that
was mentioned that I'm not aware of that
aha that company but it
just just just to provide some
information I learned three minutes ago
um I was looking for the website for the
program and it's EpiPen for you know
numeral for
schools.com and in the FAQ they say it's
a free Nationwide program offered by the
marketer and distributor of EP
to help you know to provide access and
it basically says what the sponsor was
describing earlier that every school can
get four doses and they will be replaced
uh diffused and so on so it seems that
all the school has to do is to apply and
show that they have the ability to
deliver medication right which every
school in New Hampshire probably has
they have a nurse or somebody who can
deliver medication and then they would
get this free Supply I think I cannot
speak for the sponsors but I think the
expectation is that that a school
applying for this and being rejected
would be a very rare and unusual
situation but I'm just guessing and I'm
sure we'll have a bit more of a
conversation on it but it seems clear
that every school who has a you
know if you if you have students that
have a valid prescription for epipens
and so on that they will qualify for
this which will supply again the four
doses a year and replaced by again just
website sorry that's fine uh same I
guess think two things so I remember the
second one it sounds like this the
active agent here is the school in
applying to this program and so it seems
like it would bypass the Department of
Education and would not have an impact
on the Department of Education you can
let me know if that's true and the
second thing
um do you have and you may not know this
but the people working on the bill and
perhaps it's in the fact thing there
does the school have to have a student
identified as someone who may have an A
anaphylactic shock or can the any school
have this regardless of that because you
don't always know you know what kids
have so I don't know who has the answers
to those two questions but those are
mine if I may jump in on the second
question
if the department is not
responsible for reimbursing school
districts for maintaining supplies
then it shouldn't be in the
legislation if it states in there that
the Department of Education has to
reimburse school districts for
maintaining the supplies and there's a
dollar appropriated for it if it passes
as written we would not be able to
reimburse those schools for maintaining
those supplies so I just want to make
that clear I don't know if you want to
clarify the legislation so it takes out
anything about the Department of
Education having to reimburse school
districts for maintaining the
supplies I think we will but I a little
concerned um so back on January 6th the
dep Department was asked for the fiscal
note on this and this bill passed the
house on consent so clearly had had a
hearing before that did the department
not answer these questions prior to that
point yes we we did yes yes yes we
answered their question about that
language we would not we've made them
aware we would not be able to I get that
concern but did you look into the
availability the no cost approach to the
whole system it sounds like you're notw
W made aware of that no oh okay all
right yeah representative Mar yeah along
the same lines the way this is written
if this EP pen program went away then it
is it would this mean that uh the
schools would maintain the epen EpiPen
program and the do Department of
Education would then have to pay for the
cost of the pens if this free program
was dissolved what would happen if the
program was dissolved given how this is
written based on how it's written that's
be any other questions for
Department uh yes repr
Melly thank you
um on line four on first page of the
bill it it says when a nurse is imployed
or contracted by the district what if
nurse can you clarify where you're
reading I think it's line four on page
one line oh line 11 I thought I'm Sor
four oh I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm looking at the wrong
okay all right yes line 11 when a nurse
is employed or contracted by the
district so I want to know what if um a
school nurse is not
district so it's my understanding that
they're required to have a school
nurse and that if the school nurse is
not there then it's the a building
administrator that then becomes that
kind of fills that
role so then my understanding then it
would fall upon that
administrator that responsibility but I
mean it's not it's not in statute it's
language other questions from the State
of the
State okay thank you very much
appreciate you being
here nasal spray isn't inconsistent with
this and then with my the time that I've
been on Jael car and being a medical
device analyst I wanted to make sure
that um we have the appropriate carrots
and SS so that school districts will
spend the 15 to 20 minutes to apply for
the program um especially because I know
the de Nephi in schools when they use it
all they have to do is say hey we use
this on a student they don't have a
prescription and they'll get a new one
sent right to them in the mail thank you
other questions for representative
Leon thank you ma'am appreciate it and
thank you for rushing the the amendment
over I assume the sh is in here now yes
prob four it's um online 24 it is now a
got it thank you thank
you rreo would you like to come back and
four uh sure I this is actually the
first I heard of a concern about this so
I I I actually don't even know the
answer to this because I was told by
another co-sponsor that we should have a
a dollar appropriated just in case
a school got denied for some reason if
that's not the case then I don't know I
don't want it to be an unfunded mandate
on the local schools so if a school got
denied for some reason yes the state
should have to pay for the epinepherine
so they said put a dollar in there even
though that's highly unlikely and that's
why it's there so while I understand
that you heard that what the department
had to say about
this yes they're wondering well they're
wondering where the money would be
coming from so they're wondering so on
on page one I mean you know on the first
page when it talked about the department
um May adopt rules under this to
implement the reimbursement process I
assumed it was it was up to them to
decide where you know which fund it came
out of or how that
worked so so your intent is that the
state is backing this up and if the free
programs end the the state's then
responsible for this program correct I
don't see the free program ending but
yes the state should be backing it up I
don't want to have another mandate on
our local schools okay please understand
what that means we certainly can't pass
it um it'll be held to go into the
budget and it's a very tight budget year
as I'm sure you're aware um and you're
potentially talking about millions of
to yeah I mean the policy is more
important so honestly taking out that's
the appropriation I mean it's probably
better just to have the policy um as
representative Lon said the purpose is
is kids can still bring their own EP and
Eon to schools the problem is 25% of the
times that you have to use it you don't
know you had an allergy and so that's
why it's needed in schools so I
understand that if we just so let's just
take that out and yeah I think it would
be better that way because then at least
we can proceed yeah we'll proceed it as
is and if it gets canceled for some
reason which I don't see that happening
we cross that bridge when we get to it
did you have a question M on Bernie
yeah yeah I'm you know I'm reasonably
comfortable with a language that sort of
protects the Department of Education um
but I am uncomfortable with they
actually being an appropriation because
we never know where that goes the other
concern I have is that there are those
individuals who are quite protective and
wanting to know a whole lot about what's
going on with their kids in schools and
what is the potential have you had any
push back for the parent who objects to
the school providing epinephrine for
their child even if it saves the child's
life there is you know you can't do this
to my child unless you give me 24 hours
notice or something there is a group of
people who have those views towards some
of these things is there any potential
that they're being pushed back about a
parent saying no you can't do that to my
child for whatever crazy reason that you
know I'm it's extreme but but um you've
seen similar things I think yeah I don't
know I that was not asked during the
education hearing
I I do see how some parents you know
don't want extra things done to their
kids without having the notice first I I
would equate this to using an ad on a
child but it's a life-saving measure um
in situations like this you probably
just ask for forgiveness later and make
repres papich thank you uh just a quick
comment on what was just said when
you're having somebody who's at risk of
losing their life on the spot which is
something that this is meant to
save consent I mean if if you if you get
an ambulance to pick you up and you're
unconscious you don't they don't need
consent to treat you they are saving
your life you'll figure out the rest
after so I understand the importance of
respecting parents rights and whatnot
but when it comes to life and or death
situations at some point you got to do
what you got to do um my my question was
really from earlier if we remove section
four about the appropriation right what
are we going to do about the rest of
paragraph uh Roman numeral six because
it says shall reimburse I mean if we say
shall reimburse and I don't have an
appropriation I don't think you can just
take Roman numeral 6 number four out I
think you kind of have to take the
entire Roman numeral six
out I'm not saying it's a good idea I'm
just saying they seem to go together so
this is something that I want
reprentative I had the same concern and
um I think my recommendation to the
sponsors would be to maybe spend a
little more time on that concern if they
want us to move forward we might need to
recess this work session for another day
so that they have a little more time to
concern representative Lon uh thank you
if I may I've actually worked closely
with the parents who are very concerned
about um Medical Care in the schools
that they don't approve they never had
any concern about immediate life-saving
care and that's one of the places where
the parents got Twisted into pretzels
because they were given forms where they
had to consent to anything and
everything under the sun or deny even
immediate life-saving care um for a
rescue or for an ambulance or even for
taking a temperature to see what the
child's temperature was um I think it's
well I appreciate that you haven't been
in the Health and Human Services
committee meetings when we have been
discussing it and you've only been
hearing the commentary from outside I
want you to rest assured that none of
these parent rights or parent privacy or
medical privacy groups ever seek to
interfere with something like rescuing a
if I
yes on pop it sorry thank you if if we I
just wanted to ask the committee if we
are going to ask the sponsors to work on
the bill a bit more to maybe clarify
exactly what the committee would be
looking to receive from them or what
what would it take to get there
because I I you know if I was the
sponsor and I didn't have a clear idea
of what to do this may not be very
helpful for me
so personally and if I may make that
very clear personally I'm fine with the
bill as is because I don't want to
impose an unfunded mandate I think the
availability of the free programs is not
at risk and frankly given that you know
this is life-saving care I don't see any
way to not ask the schools to have this
life saving thing there now we can talk
about whether it should be funded
directly by the doe or we can put some
money somewhere in a school funding
thing right but I would say that given
that right now this does not seem to
cost anything other than some admin time
to apply for a free thing I think I'm
comfortable passing the bill as is
knowing that in the future we may if
somehow the landscape changes so much
you know start reimbursing and frankly I
think the department in the ru making
ability may have the ability to say you
know
will uh if if the availability of the
free products is no longer there then
we'll have to figure it out in 6 months
or one year or until the next budget
comes I don't know but I think there is
enough leeway for the Department to
adopt rules that would protect us from
an unexpected need for lots of funds and
given the critical nature of you know
the need to have this things in school
I'm comfortable but again if the
majority of the committee would like
more work please try to indicate to the
sponsors what you're looking for so they
can do what they need to
do that's representa Kelly uh yes I
think that since the department has
expressed some concerns that they should
be consulted as to what the effects are
from leaving this language this way and
I don't think jel car should be messing
around with what the intent was when we
passed it I don't think that's under
their jurisdiction to clarify policy
that's already been passed that would be
my opinion thank
you uh thank you uh I think I am a
member of Jael car I'm actually the vice
chair of Jael car and um the language
was written in this way in order to show
that the intention is first do the free
programs and say why you're rejected if
not come come with a reason why not and
then the language about adopting rules
for the most fiscally um Mo I guess
Financial I don't have the specific
language but basically protect the State
while protecting kids I think is a far
more clear legislative intent than we
have in many many other bills and rules
that come in front of us I would note
that the amount of time that it'll take
to draft the language for this to pass
and then for them to draft the rules and
then get the point where we would be
adopting rules and there may even be a
chance for this reimbursement wouldn't
even happen during this upcoming budget
inless um some sort of unless something
happened very very quickly um we're
going to have an opportunity for them to
work on these rules but there won't be a
chance to reimburse it until um probably
starting at least 2 years from now just
when you look at the entire time frame
and the normal process so the question I
have is if this is if these things are
all free to the
all because as much as people ask for
local control they seem to ask for
direction from the legislature for what
they do I think it's it's a really
unfortunate disconnect um and I wish we
could get past the idea of it's local
control but you must tell us what to do
but does the direction have to be
related to money could it just be you
talked about something with the
prescriptions and St school and all that
kind of thing what have we limited the
bill to that so they just basically says
enabling legislation if you
will um thank you enabling legislation
already passed uh already passed the
house so there's already enabling
legislation for the prescription we
already had enabling legislation for the
auto injectors but schools aren't
getting these and they're not applying
for them um the question is why maybe
it's because it's so far down the totem
toll I can't imagine the idea that not
having a rescue medication that you can
get for free isn't one of the highest
priorities of every single School
District but the fact that school
districts don't have them suggests that
that suggest that um they haven't
listened to the gentle suggestions yet
so what if just mandated it left it a
that like other mandates we put out
there that they
ignore no no that's a serious question
um I I think it's a great question we
have many policies in my school district
that are not consistent with current law
um how do we deal with that well my
point is this if what you're saying is
that we need force them to do this and
it really is free and you want to give
them a push so it could mandate it I
can't imagine that
schools that saw a mandate that wasn't
costing them anything wouldn't be
inclined to go along I'll leave this to
you I I can't understand it either but I
don't want to step on the prime
sponsor's toes on this no no you're
doing a good job I
I I don't understand it either um one
it's life- saving and two it's free why
schools aren't doing it already I have
no idea
but I also don't want to be sitting here
saying oh we should have done something
if God forbid it child dies next year in
the school system because it wasn't done
so I it's a simple thing that doesn't
really cost any money so maybe the
committee could give me you know their
thoughts what do you all think of
this I'm totally supportive of the
policy um I mean as you said why
wouldn't you do this um and I guess I
would my brothers would be to have the
policy basically be bulletproof and my
concerns with the um talking about the
reimbursements and what you have to do
in order to get it or to have a line
item
appropriation um makes me feel that this
is something that could sort of derail
this um again that might be a very
extreme reaction from but you who knows
what can happen here um and so I'd be
comfortable without any of the
appropriation I would you know I totally
support the policy and I'd like to make
sure the policy is basically bulletproof
what anything else would go to it so but
papovich so here's a thought I read the
current language of 200 coln 44
DB and basically it says that the school
May authorize to use it and so on and so
forth right and it says that they are
free to go to ask for no charge fair
market prices so that's the existing
thing so first I don't worry about the
Mandate because the DN thing is already
in laow we wouldn't be mandating
anything that's not already there but if
we want to get rid of this whole
appropriation concern for the committee
I would suggest that we can just get rid
of the whole part two of the bill don't
even edit
244b except to add the reference to the
nasal
sprays which currently is not there
right now it just says
injectors and this way you know you have
to maintain
it the free programs are available I
don't think anybody can complain about
an unfunded mandate if the supplies are
free and if at some point in time this
is no longer free and easily available a
future you know budget will look into
how to reimburse the schools for it if
it becomes a problem but at this point
in
time look look I hate spending money
especially other people's money okay but
I mean you're talking about at most 100
or 200 and the prices may drop over time
as this is more generic and whatnot and
patents expire and all that and you're
talking about the potential death on the
school grounds that could have been
easily prevented by a simple you know
easily available
medication I think I would personally be
fine passing the bill as is because I
don't think the appropriation is going
to be any significant risk because if
the committee is really worried about it
if we have an amendment that changes
section two to only add the references
to the nasal spray instead of saying the
Department of Education is
involved I would be fine with that I'm
just brainstorming here to see if the
committee has an interest in any of this
and uh again I apologize to the sponsors
if I'm mangling the bill in ways they
didn't intend I I'm just trying to find
a you know good
outcome the only thing I would keep is
the uh the annual report going to the
Department of Education because right
now some states have it um we don't
national average um on the low end six
out of 100,000 students need an
epinephrine dose during the school year
on the high end it's 22 out of 100,000
pupils so it is needed uh but we have no
data in New Hampshire to say this is how
many times it happened so keep that but
yes if if it concerns everybody else
about the uh reimbursement portion then
yes we can remove that so so just to
clarify we're talking about specifically
removing section two part Roman numeral
six that whole paragraph on page one and
then on the back page we're talking
four are you working from the original
bill or the Amendments I'm working from
what you just hand just out so you're
removing which parts um section number
two
uh Roman numeral
six
okay and then section four and then
section four okay and then that adds the
assisted personnel with anaphylaxis
training and the annual annual
report okay Mr chair yes ma'am uh so I'm
I'm just looking at the RSA now and my
initial comment still stands because
there are additional sections in RSA 200
col
44b that are not being changed that has
permissive language but if we're only
changing section subsection five
according to this new Amendment um we're
going to have a disagreement in law
between Ma and shs
and no I'm talking about um so this is
page one of the
amendment line 19 and
Below whatever we retain this this is
changing RSA 200
44b and the issue is that if you only
change subsection five the current law
sections 1 through four have permissive
language but now section five will have
mandatory language so again my initial
comment about having the sponsors maybe
um spend a little more time with with
particularly the lawyers OS who can help
them with this Lang
redraft could you perhaps just read
maybe one of the one two three or fours
of of the real manal just so I
understand why you have a problem with
SH being in one of the subsections not
everyone so it says a school board
subsection one says a school board May
authorize a school nurse who is employed
by the school district for whom the
board is responsible to maintain the
supply um so if you keep going down it
sounds like it's changing right
um the permissive language because now
our our the higher sections up the page
say say shall
right I thought you said they say may
they do under current law okay so I'm
just I think that maybe more eyeballs
need to be put on this I I don't want to
rush us to a decision that might put
contradictions between Ma and shells and
existing line you are the attorney but I
can read English yeah I think if you
come to a subsection that says sh You'
know that for the annual report part
it's a sh
as opposed to the other pieces it sounds
like it's a May or am I misunderstanding
what you're saying about the other sub
pieces
um I'm just afraid that the intent that
the sponsors may have is not what we'll
read on the paper if we were to move to
that do this do the witnesses have any
concerns or comments Ian I mean I think
it's pretty straightforward that the
report that you would do is say well we
chose not to do this we chose not to
apply essentially saying we chose not to
apply for this free program that would
give me f ANF and we chose not to so
we're not giving it to any of our
students they just have an opportuni to
submit that report that they shall
submit um I mean honestly maybe if you
have to put in a report that says yeah
we didn't bother to apply for the free
Goods um maybe that'll end up being the
the carrot that we need instead of the
Stick of the overall shell um but I I
mean I I just I don't want to talk my
question is about talking for all the
other co-sponsors who who are really
pushing to make sure that this is as
strong and robust as possible because um
most of them have kids in their family
that have anaphylactic reactions and
they remember what it was like before
they had remember what life was like
before they had that diagnosis and they
know there's other kids sitting in our
at school desks that don't know yet that
they have an anaphylactic reaction to
something so I don't want to say that I
personally I'm not going to say that
just saying the annual report is going
to make these school districts fall into
line my other question would be do we
just push through and put this into the
everybody representative Murray um just
sort of as a touch Point
um Health and Human Services has
approved the policy and we're con
supposed to be concerned just with the
money part of it and so um being just my
concern is sort of protecting Department
of Education from having a big a big you
know whatever even if it's a small
amount but um as far as you know there
may be issues with the policy but Health
and Human Services already passed the
policy so actually Health and Human
Services passed a different policy that
allowed nasal sprays this bill went to
education policy which is why we had the
different languages coming out through
the first vote on the floor but
education policy said end fully endorsed
on consent the idea that while we're all
trying to save money um sometimes
backstopping a free program makes
sense so I guess I would ask if anybody
would be willing to make a motion that
we amend the bill with amendment number
0575 modified to delete section two
four section two Roman numeral 6 not not
four represent papovich I will make a
motion as uh suggested by the chairman
to amend the bill to uh well to amend
the
amendment
0575 to
remove two number two Roman numeral six
and to also remove section four and
renum all sections
second before proceeding Mr
weran oh sorry representative Hain
Phillips and representative papovich
made the motion um basically the two
hyphenated names are in Mr land again is
that too much to no you can handle that
yeah I I didn't get a copy of the new
Amendment so I'm assuming is the only
change just that made a sh that's been
it repres Leon do you have another copy
of the amendment I do you could give one
of the Department of Education maybe yes
I can give uh one of these copies to no
no no I want it for you you have from oh
I already gave them to the Department of
Education thank you that's all I wanted
to do I I should have gone for the 20 I
said 12 with the number of people I
didn't realize how much markup we would
be doing I'm I
apologize um that's a good question so
maybe we could have the department come
say so maybe folks in the department of
of Education could come back
and tell me you still hate this bill no
we're a free range committee here I just
want to clarify I don't hate I don't
love we are remain completely neutral
and just want to make sure we're
pointing out if it were to pass we
wouldn't be able to do anything and
that's the type of legislation I like to
point out because if there is a a price
tag associated with it but nothing
appropriated I can't do anything in that
puts this all in a bad I apologize for
being factious but do you how do you
feel about the amendment with those
pieces
removed do you want to speak to that
sure um I think um to to representative
hack's Point um what's in current I
think that the maybe the sponsors just
to clarify what's in current law um just
make sure that if they're looking to
either repeal it or um just make sure
that the amendment matches what's in
current law um because it it might be a
little bit contradict on the ma versus
the shells um depending on what so
because honestly I I I can speak English
I'm just kind of curious as to what
there's separate independent sentences
four of them say May and the fifth one
says shall doesn't there's no
there this is repealed and reenacted so
the current language will Disappear
five or
four Roman numeral four so four in
current law the if the intent of the
bill is to mandate them could you read
four so we know it's it says a school
may enter into an agreement with a
manufacturer of epinephrine Auto
injectors their party suppliers of
epinephrine Auto injectors or healthc
care offices to obtain the epinephrine
Auto injectors at no charge or at Fair
market prices or at reduced prices a
school district May accept gifts grants
or donations from foundations
organizations or private parties to
purchase the epinephrine Auto
injectors we're requiring them to do
this no you we're requiring them to
provide an annual
report that's where the Sha is you just
read maze not
shells in current law so if the proposed
legislation wants to require them to do
this in current them to do what to enter
into the agreement to get the free
epipens we're not trying to require them
okay
right lines
of
okay yeah
okay I me you get that we're only adding
section Roman numeral 5 to three
existing Roman four existing Roman
Philips uh it's entirely up to the
sponsors how they want to move forward
with this I would leave it to them if
they think they need more time if they
don't that's also fine I just think you
know whatever the end result is it's
going to be their bill so they should be
able to defend it I guess whatever way
they want to go I thought they had but
we'll have them up here one more time to
confirm and you so you're okay with
where we are now as far as the concerns
the Department of Education has as far
as for the Department of Education our
part is is clear okay thank you our
marching orders are clear okay thank you
and maybe the sponsors can come back up
and just confirm they want to go forward
with this and and I would just say that
the reason I'm being
the question is do we push this forward
because right now we could put an outp
out get it through the house off to the
Senate and see what happens otherwise it
hangs out and we retain it it hangs out
until we do the budget and
then I don't know what happens so I I
leave it in your hands in terms of which
route you'd rather us
take I think taking out what we talked
about and leaving the rest still leaves
the intent of the bill and just gets rid
of some of the confusion so I'm okay
with doing that okay and representative
I know it's not your bill but do you
feel the same way yes I'm definitely all
right with that okay and Mr land again
you're comfortable with what we're
talking about here okay so we have a
motion on the table it's the
OTP uh amendment number 20250
055 excuse me
h no 0575 oh God that's right I don't
have I don't have the actual
I got
it yeah you're right I'm sorry I was I'd
given mine
away you can have mine you can keep mine
I'm
good so I'll start
again a motion on the
table to amend HB
677 with Amendment 2025
d575 H modified to strike section two
Roman numeral
6 and then also strike section four and
of course we number all the sections uh
accordingly so I guess my first question
is does that Amendment make
sense
okay Madame clerk when you're ready you
sorry representative
papich I representative Bean yes
representative Dy yes representative
Murray yes
representative
hackin Phil sorry yes thank
you representative Kelly
yes
representative
so thank you both for your considerable
time I really appreciate it I hope we
get what we need what you need out of
this and have fun with the Senate thank
you um hang hang on one second I don't
were you read off the first bill that
they gave us or the
amendment so what was the motion could
you tell me what did you write the
motion was from
your you Marketa
just no just a man h
chair yes I I know what you're asking
and we'll do that but remember all we're
so
e
okay one is it does it do we need to
have a separate motion to say we want to
enough I'd say you're far enough but if
you want to belt in suspenders I mean
typ typically you should have done a
vote to uh for an amendment and then
well that's sort of how they took it so
yeah um I would say that that's up to
the committee to decide how you want to
handle it I I really want to help my
poor Vice chair out he's very concerned
so I'll entertain another motion
to otpa with the amendment that we just
modified so who who who moved it you did
I'd like to move the amendment to otpa
Bill 677 as amended disc described in
the previous motion
second oh sure second represent of
Murray
seconds and when you're ready represent
role representative papichi Papi EXC me
I representative Bean yes representative
dor yes representative Murray yes
representative hackin Phillips yes
representative Kelly yes okay uh
representative Earth yes so move 7 to
zero thank you madam clerk okay so that
one goes there any other discussion the
committee and I apologize if I was too
rash in some of my
comments okay that was interesting yes
sir one thing you may want to figure out
is um typically when you go to the full
committee usually whoever makes the
motion in the second will make the
motion in the second across the way and
then speak to those bills I don't think
we've officially said okay represent
whomever is going to speak to that bill
in the full committee I don't know if
you just want to make that clear moving
forward is is anybody willing
to make the motion and speak to the that
in
committee well you you've just done the
you've already done the motion
everything so in this case it would be
representative age I'm just ask somebody
to agree I'm not making any
motions I'm fine with it you're happy to
someone's gonna have to tell me what I
motioned
on WE we'll we'll Mickey will tell you
that so representative Murray will make
the motion and the Motions I the ones I
mooved I will speak in the I
think go through them typically Janet
will put together that sheet for you for
the exec sessions that'll let everyone
know what the divisions recommendations
were and who may I'm just this is just a
friendly reminder so nobody's blindsided
that they may have to speak to one of
the BS and one of the decisions made in
here when you get across the way so you
don't necessarily have to do anything
today about it it's just you want us to
review the ones that she she has them on
her this is for your own personal
benefit the committee you can you can go
through them today if you want I think
I've got my notes here too we can just
make sure everyone's clear on yeah why
why don't you why don't we do that make
sure who we're close the people here
not you who made the Motions
today I think the first two bills
representative Murray made the motion of
ought to pass it's based on my notes
Here the first two bills today no I had
no I had um making the motion on 677
right on the the first the first two
bills oh the first two
bills
motion hold on the motion she it's on
your I know it's here somewhere where
are we 165 okay all right okay the first
motion was made by representative Murray
had hital one
two okay that one was
motion the motion was made by uh
representative Murray and secutive
by yeah and that was
okay then 617 677
677 will RSE
First and M and representative Murray
both and then on then we had the
amendment with changes was uh a motion
by representative hacken Phillips and
then I mean she was second and then
papichi was uh the made the
motion
yeah that was the amendment yeah that's
not relevant because we won't discuss
the Amendments
separately okay so basically it's
represent Mur for the first two bills
and I am on the
okay so hope I get a better at the
said okay there's nothing else come
before us I
will close the finance division 2
meeting at
coming and we meet again Monday wish
next